president Trump will land in Vietnam
soon for his highly anticipated second
summit with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un before he left the United States
the president said he's not in a rush to
get North Korea to give up its nuclear
weapons as long as there are no tests
him arrived in Vietnam several hours ago
after a two and a half day train ride
through China people lined the streets
to get a look at the first North Korean
leader to visit in more than 50 years
then Tracie is in Viet Nam's capital of
Hanoi where the summit will be held
then good morning good morning so this
has been billed as a two-day summit here
in Vietnam and the White House now says
that President Trump will meet Kim Jong
moon here in Hanoi Wednesday night for
dinner their official summit meetings
will take place then on Thursday but
since he arrived first so far it's been
- Kim Jong Un's show when the North
Korean leader arrived in Vietnam he was
wearing a black suit and a big smile Kim
jong-un seemed relieved to be done with
his 60 hour train ride from Pyongyang
once inside his armored Mercedes he even
rolled down the window The Dictator
known for starving and killing his own
people looked like a seasoned politician
when he arrived at his hotel in Hanoi
North Korean security agents left
nothing to chance
a bellman tells CBS News that all of Kim
Jong Un's food cooking supplies and even
forks and knives were brought in from
North Korea but what he's willing to do
without is the question of this summit
North Korea take any concrete steps
towards denuclearization before leaving
Washington President Trump previewed the
argument he'll make - Kim we want the
nuclearization and I think he'll have a
country that will set a lot of records
for speed in terms of an economy kim
jeong-hoon desperately wants relief from
crippling economic sanctions but he
doesn't yet seem willing to trade his
nuclear weapons to get it even if it
would improve the lives of his
impoverished people I think North Korea
also needs to understand that they can't
eat nuclear weapons Chonan bomb is a
former Lieutenant General of the South
Korean army do you really believe North
Korea after all this time and all this
money is actually going to give these
weapons up I personally think that's
going to be a hard process but even if
they decide to do so it's going to take
15 20 years
in what appears to be a case of
seriously bad planning it turns out that
the hotel where the White House press
corps was assigned to work from here in
Illinois is also the hotel where Kim
Jong moon is staying
when he arrived this morning all of the
journalists were kicked out and the
hotel says that North Korean security
agents are now in charge really
interesting details there have never
heard anyone talk about eating a nuclear
weapon and Tracy and Vietnam thank you